c'est un rendez vous dont ils se
seraient bien passés à frasne commune de
2000 habitants
les électeurs sont appelés aux urnes à
seulement trois mois des municipales
j'ai rempli mon devoir de citoyenne
c'est quoi tout en pensant que c'est
très nul quoi voilà c'est désolant
je trouve que c'est dommage ça manque un
peu de dignité
voilà pourquoi ben parce qu'au sein d'un
conseil on doit quand même réussir à
travailler ensemble même si on est en
opposition
ce dimanche ils doivent départager deux
listes deux camps issus du même conseil
municipal des bisbilles internes ont mis
en minorité le maire actuel avant la fin
de son second mandat
philippe alpy se présente donc face à un
ancien adjoint
après quatre ans difficile c'est une
vision une mise au point mise au clair
et pas un conseil sans tension puis 2015
c'est systématique
le maire a dit donc ce que dit mr ces
fonds après plusieurs démissions puis la
destitution en septembre de deux
adjoints à la suite de discorde
le conseil est réduit si la loi
permettait de poursuivre la gestion de
la commune
l'opposition en a décidé autrement
votons pour des élections anticipées
ça fait quand même un moment qu'on
contredit certains de ses projets bon ça
bon ça avait l'art de l'agacer mais bon
il arrive un moment où il faut se
décider il faut dire voilà on n'est pas
d'accord
pourquoi on n'est pas d'accord et puis
on n'en serait pas venu là dans une
certaine confusion ces élections
ressemble bien à une répétition un
avant-goût du scrutin de mars prochain